[Music]
I've connected it with another friend of
mine to help him with like meditation
stuff in New York City
Emily Fletcher have you ever heard of
MIT Emily she runs sounds familiar I
don't know her she's a book coming out
right away to stress less accomplish
more she's fantastic former like
Broadway actress and singer whatever
just an amazing spirit person she's just
amazing yeah cool I think I have heard
of her I've heard of that yeah I think
yeah I mean it's coming out and I like
to come and comes out like two weeks
after mine many ways if you ever do
something with them cuz they ever I mean
that's a massive network we work is yeah
I'm hooked up with some folks out here
on in that space so you know yeah this
is something to explore but in any event
dude this is about you nice to have you
here today
thank you for got a text from Jonathan
fields several weeks ago and he's like I
got a guy who I think you're gonna dig
my good buddy Todd he's on your page
he's all about peak performance and
working with athletes and executives to
you know unlock the best version of
themselves yeah you guys should
definitely hook up and I was like yeah
sounds sounds like my kind of guy yeah I
was in New York last week and we
connected and here we are man yeah this
is how fast it works usually this fast
like normally it's like months and
months if not years to like yeah pin
down I guess for the pod but this was
fast-tracked yeah that's why you have
good friends like Jonathan it's just
squeeze the grape faster well anybody
that Jonathan would refer to me I would
welcome with open arms because I love
that man I love everything that he's
about and if he's saying that we should
connect man I trust that wholeheartedly
thankful for that yeah so good to have
you here today
very exciting times for you you know
this book coming out very soon
definitely alter-ego effect it's just
great I just got my copy the other day
so I will admit that I'm not done
reading it yet but yeah I'm I'm about
25% into it and at this point and I'm
really taking it dude it's a cool idea
so let's work our way up to the ideas in
the book though yeah
you're somebody who has created a career
and you've been doing this for a long
time 97 since 90s and you're a young
dude yeah well I'm 43 I started the
started super young working right you
know young athletes but yeah working
with athletes Olympic athletes
professional athletes and now business
executives and all manner of people to
help them become unblocked and unleash
their the their peak performances right
just whatever whatever genius like they
have yeah you know remove the remove the
emergency brake on their performance
like I say we're gonna release it just
10% then we can that means we can
release it 10% more and keep on going
what are the biggest blocks that you
come across in working with these
athletes like what are the common things
that most people struggle with in terms
of you know kind of taking their talent
and their expertise to the next level
there are a lot there are one one large
one that doesn't get talked about enough
is definitely trauma something from
their past that has turned into a little
bit of a demon that can stop them from
seeing what their possibility is for
themselves definitely I mean of the
hundreds and hundreds of like more elite
athletes that I've worked with 82% to
them I've referred off to get help with
a therapist or someone else on just
helping them unblock some of that past
trauma stuff
82% yeah well I mean 105 says well I'm a
data guy I really track stuff a lot and
so you know is 82% the exact number no
but that that's about the right number
it's definitely if I had if I had 10 of
them in front of me I know for a fact
eight of them have gone or I've referred
eight of them off because again like I'm
helping with people with mental game
strategies and P performance strategies
which is all about helping them to move
forward and compete even 5% better
tomorrow than they did today or 1% like
we're just looking for marginal
improvements because if when you stack
them all up it creates a big difference
of course
and unlike some people who want to take
what they have as a skillset and think
they can solve everyone's problems with
it I don't I stayed very much in my lane
and the moment I've poked and found
caramel I'm crawling around between the
six inches of their ears trying to find
hey what's that thing that's that pebble
in their shoe that's kind of stopping
them or you know trying to give them new
strategies and when you're building up
such high levels of trust with people
you end up just having really raw and
honest conversations with people mm-hmm
and the moment I found that I was like
whoa I am NOT a skilled therapist that's
not my game and so I'm gonna definitely
refer you refer you off however that
doesn't mean that that person needs to
go to the sidelines and quit on whatever
it is they're doing right
how often is is that trauma something
that the athlete is consciously aware of
very very little yeah yeah it's not
something and I can speak to it very
honestly because it was the thing that I
dealt with I had a very rough experience
when I was a young yeah well let's talk
let's talk about that I mean you you
kind of made passing reference to that
when we met in New York
yeah and I went back and looked at your
Facebook post where you you know wrote
eloquently about this experience that
you had yes I walk walk me through that
yeah well as a little bit of background
I grew up on a big farm and ranch
outside of Medicine Hat Alberta which is
south of Calgary which you know for
people who aren't from it was candidate
all it's on in the in the prairie
provinces and kind of middle of nowhere
is where I grew up but Medicine Hat
Medicine Hat yet got its name because
back when you know the you know English
and were sort of colonizing everything
they found a Native American tribe and
when they fled they swim across the
river and the medicine man lost his hat
and so that God that settlement that
makes me like lose faith in humanity
like really it's dom i have it's that
simple
yeah it's that simple yeah canada is
fantastic four great names for first
cities
in towns but yeah so I mean I grew up in
a farm family and I would always longed
to be around people all the time because
it was very much isolated so I would
constantly ask when summer time hit that
I wanted to go to whatever church camp
was available so if there was a catholic
camp this weekend I'd be a Catholic and
if there was a Presbyterian one next
weekend I'd hit right didn't matter to
me I just wanted to go and be around
people and when I was 12 I went off to a
church camp and unfortunately had an
experience where two men over the course
of a couple of days sexually assaulted
me and after that when I was coming home
you know it just robs you I don't go
into the details about right but
multiple occasions abuse then yeah and
kind of the worst part about it is just
the the systematic nature with which
they developed that trust with you and
then break you down kind of thing and
that's been something that I held onto
for a really really really long time
by myself but I came home and I was very
honestly at the Facebook post you're
kind of referring to was kind of which
is very new I just said it to the world
for the first time in fact right before
I posted that I read it to my parents
and my siblings for the first time
because it's not the first instance of
you addressing this yeah and with people
that you care about in your life no it
wasn't the first instance the first
instance was about 16 months before
where basically I just kind of hit a
breaking point where I was going through
a major business lawsuit
you know this this book anyone who has
written a book knows the challenges of
getting your thoughts down on paper
especially when you're first-time author
like myself and that stress had just
brought me to kind of a breaking point
I'm I'm a new newish dad I mean I've got
three little kids and my wife had gone
through a pretty bad last pregnancy with
her third youngest boy and yeah so it
just all of a sudden it all came to a
head and but prior to that it was
decades of departmentalization three
decades and trying to just say this was
in the past I'm moving forward
protego knowing apon yeah ignoring it
and suppressing it and you even forget a
lot of the details about it and then
when you start getting help with it
there's all these things that you know
get revealed that have shaped your
behavior that you would have never
guessed you know for example I've been
I've been known and it's been on my
social media stuff for a long time kind
of as a bit of a needle to myself but
that I'm a massive root beer aficionado
love root beer and it wasn't until going
through you know in getting help on this
about five months ago even I was talking
to the psychiatrist that I was working
with and working with and it all of a
sudden came to it that the very last
drink that I had before the incident
happened was it was a root beer and so
for my entire life basically trying to
go back to that little kid and prior to
prior to the incident and that's my kind
of my last known memory of just being
you know an innocent kid kind of thing
so it was a source of inability to
manage your life that culminated in a
crisis flash point in which you realized
you had to confront this and deal with
it yeah I mean the big one of the big
tipping points was I was picking up my
you know I live in New York City now and
I was picking up my two little daughters
from preschool and as I put I put Sophie
into the the carriage and then I picked
up Molly my oldest one who's you know
four at the time to put her in and as I
did she put her hand up to my cheek and
she said daddy are you happy and I said
yeah I'm happy and she said oh cuz
you've been yelling at us a lot lately
and it's making us sad and I just lost
it right there broke down because now
all of a sudden I had been confronted
with this internal reality which was
manifesting now into just me
hurting my kids in small ways since you
have an awareness that that was being
fueled or driven by this childhood
trauma no no it wasn't that I mean I
there was just this all of it there's
only so long that you can hold on to
that emotion before it just bubbles up
and to just sort of poorer behavior you
know whether it's anger or rage and just
the culmination of so many different
events coming together the exact same
time
just you know was turning me into a
massively stressed out person and this
is coming from someone who has practiced
meditations since you know before it was
very cool he was before yoga was cool
and I have a lot of the tools and the
toolkit to do it but then after a
certain point in time you know some
people maybe they can keep it bottled up
but when you're constantly striving and
still achieving it's really hard to keep
on running with the the the line in the
in the red area of your RP yes well and
that just compounds to the shame so
you're starting from a baseline point of
harboring a tremendous amount of shame
because on some level I would imagine
you feel responsible for this trauma
happening yeah begin with yeah and so
shamed by it that you can't talk about
it or share it with anybody that keeps
you stuck in it yeah and then you become
this high-performance coach and this
parent who yes meditator this person who
has all these tools in these practices
and you're still handicapped by this
which makes you feel even more
disempowered yeah which just completely
you know accelerates the vicious cycle
yeah
and I mean you brought up two big things
to two major emotions that shape
people's performance and how they
operate in life our shame and guilt it's
just they're just insidious how much
they prevent people from you know I talk
about the idea of the heroic self that's
that's really sitting inside of all of
us that is waiting to get unlocked and
you know even for me because you know I
have worked with some extremely
successful people over the course of my
career but I've always stayed in the
periphery I've never you know tried to
pursue like a personal brand name for
Todd Herman and then once I started
getting into this really kind of
clearing this out of my system it was
just so evident and became evident that
it was because I didn't want someone to
fundamentally find out that this
happened to me at some point in time
which kind of got to the the purpose of
the post I actually was sitting down it
was New Year's Eve night December 31st
and was about to kind of map out my year
just some ideas or
thoughts about what how I wanted the
year to go which I'd already done but I
was just kind of fine-tuning it and all
of a sudden this is the stuff that came
out because I just fundamentally felt
like I really wanted 2019 to be
something very different for myself and
I wanted to let that go for the final
time and not carry it with me because
it's not my fault I didn't do it to
myself and yeah I didn't I mean it's
it's definitely my point wasn't to help
other people with it it was to really
help myself with it but it I've actually
talked to seven different people who
have reached out to me privately since
then about how close they were to
suicide as well and had conversations
yeah I'm sure there's a lot of people
who read that who have had similar
experiences and you can't move forward
until you clean house yeah and you will
hold on to that shame for as long as
possible until it becomes no longer
tenable and you know we don't need to
get into the graphic details of this
story if people want to read it you can
go to your Facebook page and read it but
there's an aspect of the story that's so
horrific that involves this event being
publicly you know yeah shared in a way
that I can't imagine the fear and the
shame that would surround that aspect of
it you know it's just it's so horrible
and it takes tremendous courage to own
that even though intellectually we all
understand and nobody would dispute the
fact that of course you're not to blame
here yeah nothing to do with you yeah to
hold that private for so long to harbor
that amount of repressed emotion
it's amazing that your life didn't fray
at the edges sooner or more
substantially that I did well I mean it
definitely I think it was constantly
being frayed at the edges I guess but
yeah I don't know there's some part of
that kind of human will to survive and
and not make it
I always had this feeling inside that
there was something bigger waiting for
me if I could actually face this kind of
this demon and you know it's still
unfolding for me I guess but yeah it I
mean I I talked about in that post that
there was many times where I attempted
suicide with it and you know there's
nothing that's that I that you would
think would maybe jar you to get some
help more than when you're sitting on a
hospital bed after taking three bottles
of pills and sucking back charcoal which
is what's used to you know try to take
away the effects of those drugs and it's
it's hard stuff to choke down that you
would maybe reach out for help but that
even then still still wouldn't do it
because that you'd kind of just that
idea of the fact that you know I was
constantly getting trolled and still do
get trolled today with people reaching
out with gifts because my incident was
videotaped and it's a very popular video
and the pedophile community apparently
and yeah people troll me to try to like
extort money from million and just you
know be not that kind and yeah so it's
horrific you know I'm so sorry that that
happened to you yeah but you seem good
yeah well I didn't like that there's
more to it than hey I'm gonna write a
Facebook post like yeah this is a public
acknowledgment of it in a way of saying
that you know I the way I refer to it as
shame can't survive the light yeah you
you refer to the Martin Luther King
quote mmm-hmm you know something about
you know you can't you can't resolve
darkness with darkness yeah that's a
starting point I'm sure there's a lot
that then went into you processing this
I mean you can own it and talk about it
and share it and and move forward yeah
well I mean it's definitely it's
definitely felt felt good to get it out
right like it's not it's cuz that whole
fear of people finding out in a god much
other just say it my way and own the
story and yeah it's not something that
because that just that constant fear of
it gonna be the thing that defines me
for the rest of my life even if someone
did find out and then saying you know
what if some wants to define me with
that story then you know go ahead I
can't control everybody and how they
perceived me so because I know I'm a lot
more than that
you know what about the two guys they're
both they're both gone there yeah
they're both dead yeah so but just to
kind of wrap this background to kind of
where we started with this is so many
people hold on like so many athletes
and/or people that are high performers
have held on to an idea of something
that happened that's hard for them as
the thing that's helped to drive them
right that they think that if they let
that thing go that they're gonna lose
their edge mm-hmm and it's and and it
just it does it keeps them operating at
an emotional rpm that's just way higher
than they need to and I think the one
thing that did allow me to be very good
at what I did early on was because of my
incident that happened to me I'm just
extraordinarily highly empathetic and
probably at a wavelength where I can
kind of connect with people that maybe
he may and may be in some way I
attracted a lot of the more you know
challenging hurt people and then maybe
that's why my 80% is is higher than I
don't know what other people's ratios
are but I mean we all know that every
human being has experienced trauma and
you know trauma is experienced by every
human being whether they're in a car
accident that can still a good
experience this trauma you know that's
just now it's the degree of it and the
narrative that gets handed to it but you
know it's the one thing that definitely
allowed me to connect with people and
probably build trust at a high level
very quickly with them yeah and beyond
that it's fascinating that you pursued
this career trajectory that was almost a
quest to answer and resolve these
questions for yourself as much as
developing you know an awareness and a
toolbox to help others yes well I think
we all do this as human beings on some
level yeah Mike when I when I shared
this with a friend of mine he said Wow
now you make so much sense to me you
know because you would tell the origin
story of why you got into like mental
toughness training and it was always
like a veneer kind of thing like your
origin story didn't sound as great as
other people's origin stories and that's
because if I actually told some of my
origins
I was gonna be revealing too much for
myself anyway but he's like now it makes
so much sense I mean you got into it
just out of survive it's a survival
story hundred percent hundred percent on
that tip about high-performing athletes
over-revving their rpms and developing
an attachment to the idea that that's
necessary for them to maintain a certain
level of performance and that is
something that I not only agree with
wholeheartedly it's something that I
suffer from and have always suffered Tom
and I have made this commitment in 2019
to shift that paradigm which I have to
tell you yeah it's been quite
uncomfortable yeah and the results have
yet to be told
yeah on this so trust me I'm gonna
harness you to make this all about me
and my problem I have the opportunity
today right well we don't have to do
that right now but but I think you know
it's an interesting way into kind of
what you do and how you do it to
evaluate hey here's what's working
here's what's not working and I'm
somebody who you know I know what it's
like to perform at a high level I also
have a fair amount of self awareness
about what my Achilles heels are yeah
but I also have this incredible
inability to do anything about it and
because of these attachments that I have
superstitions or OCD behaviors yeah
around what it would mean to let go of a
certain behavior pattern and try
something different yeah well I mean I
withour set it on stages or I set it
just with people privately you know when
you take a look at a company there's a
CEO there's a CMO there's a chief
operating officer and all those three
people will sit inside the company and
they can operate at a high level inside
the company but there is a role nowadays
that's coming to kind of fruition which
is a chief performance officer and I've
always thought of myself that way and
the thing about a chief performance
officer is it is impossible for a
performance anyone who's trying to help
someone perform to be inside the bottle
with you you know is the classic you
can't read the
label when you're inside the bottle and
a performance officer or someone who's
helping the performance has to by nature
be sitting outside of you to be able to
get context not be so emotionally
engaged that's why we all need coaches
so much because that coach can you know
reflect back to you more easily than you
can because you're so wrapped up in the
narrative of who you are and this is how
I am and all that kind of this is the
way I've always done it and you know
unless you become that person who can be
coachable which is a very difficult
thing for people to allow it's it's
actually quite amazing how many people
are not willing to be coachable I was
one of those people who is not a
coachable person until I had an amazing
coach break that paradigm for me and
then all of a sudden I was like oh wait
yeah life becomes so much easier when
you can lean on other smarter
relationships than your own so well it
requires a little bit of self esteem and
and Trust right absolutely and I think
receptivity to the idea that whatever
story you're telling yourself about
yourself is probably flawed yeah yeah
right yeah so the story that I tell well
first of all the idea of a chief
performance officer I think is great it
reminds me of the maggie siff character
and billions who's do you watch that
show like yes she's basically that's
what she does that's her role she's a
shrink but she's there to get the best
out of all of these boys right and they
go in and they they drop their secrets
on her and their fears and all of that
and she helps them hear all that stuff
out I think every company should have
somebody like that yeah right yeah and
then you kind of do this individually
for individuals I met I've done it with
companies as well of course too but uh
yeah what well I just it's just been
such I mean it's such an interesting
conversation for me anyways like that
I'm hearing about because it's just I
would never would have thought I get to
the point where I'm on a podcast talking
about my my history like this and not be
breaking down into a puddle on the floor
you you you you're more than welcome to
cry other people have yeah yeah we'll
see how it goes I could get you there we
want to make that a priority
I can work my way towards that let's
let's see how it happens organically
alright so the story that that I've
always told myself is I'm not the
smartest I'm not the most talented
athlete hmm but if I have a talent or a
superpower it is an ability to outwork
the guy next to me a higher capacity to
suffer and outlast and I will leverage
that to bridge the talent deficit gap
and get on top yeah and what that
requires is a certain level of
commitment that is probably deeper than
the other person control issues
perfectionism and that leads into some
OCD around habits you know when it's
when you're trying to make everything
perfect everything has to be just so
I've got to control it yeah and the
minute that I relinquish any control or
I say look it doesn't have to be perfect
because I've taken care of this is the
beginning of the mmm-hmm mhm
and in the context of kind of what I do
now I've grown this enterprise to a
certain point doing things a certain way
and it's been successful yeah but to get
to the next level I have to I can't do
things the way that I always have I have
to build teams I have to empower people
around me I have to let go of certain
things and I can't pay attention to the
details as deeply as I'm used to because
I have other things that are vying for
my attention that are equally as
important yeah and this is terrifying
for me yeah yeah yeah and so what is but
what's the consternation around that
like what's the what's the really
challenging part of that for you the
challenging part is if I let people in
and I release my my stronghold on the
reins that it's all going to fall apart
mm-hmm mm-hmm so there's this one of my
favorite sports I ever were
with and still work with is equestrian
because it's one of the few sports where
you have a partner that is a mirror
reflection of what's going on inside of
you and you know when you think about
when you're out there running you know
someone can look at your face or your
body language and they could say always
focus Tory's like whatever but when
you're on a horse a horse that's why
horses are used in therapy for you know
you know people who've got autism or any
one of a matter of many PTSD when you're
on a horse and if you're feeling anxious
and if you're feeling stressed inside
your horse is gonna get jittery yeah and
will reflect that it will reflect it
immediately and and even to down to you
know if you if you you're even holding
the reins of a horse lightly but you're
still feeling stressed those reins will
pass that emotion through to the horse
and so that's why they were always if I
could get an equestrian rider to like
shift their stress levels into a calm
state then you know I can kind of do any
I can work with a body there's such a
great challenging group to work with and
so it's that you know you're talking
about like releasing that and they're
more stress that you're holding on to to
kind of grip the neck of your company or
your business or your enterprise
whatever it's all it's doing is creating
a stressful environment not only for you
to be operating it but ever for everyone
else to be operating in and then it
there is no opportunity for your
business to be supple supple is just a
word I love to go to because it's just
well I just I'm a fan of the word well
here's the other part of the the story
kind of the backdrop here yeah and and
hopefully it answers this question about
the stress level and that is that I tell
myself that if I'm not because I have
this capacity to suffer that if I
haven't really mind that mm-hmm with
respect to a project whether it's
athletic or professional that I haven't
really given my all and I have not shown
up for it to the extent that I
capable so I have to create an
environment in which it's I create pain
for myself yeah because if I don't
experience that on a visceral level when
I'm trying to birth something into the
world then I haven't really I haven't I
you know I haven't really shown up for
it in the way that I could and the end
result will not be as good as I know
that it can be yeah
so that of course creates that stress
but on some level I'm addicted to that
stress because I feel like I need to
feel that in order to validate the
effort yeah
and so but when you're going through
that is there is there a part of you
that enjoys that process at all in a
perverse way yeah
in a perverse way it feels very
uncomfortable to adopt a different
mindset or perspective on this which is
to say what if it was easy right and
like this is kind of a thing that people
are saying what if it was easy what if
you could navigate this with grace and
ease and a lack of stress and presence
of mind what would that feel like and
one might say well that would feel great
but for me that's terrifying because
that means that I am poking a hole in
that story yeah that I need to suffer to
create something of value yeah yeah yeah
when you think about your values what
are some of the things that you value
the most in my personal life you mean
yeah in like you know whether it's the
world or especially like how you see
yourself like what what what does rich
rule value I value my relationships I
value integrity mm-hmm I value striving
to align the public version of myself
with the private version like being an
integrated person mm-hmm and I value a
life of service giving back yes super
important to me yeah and I'm sure that
we can go on and family and like you
know yeah plenty of other things I mean
I could go down the line
yeah I mean in the short time that I've
got to know you I would say all those
things definitely come to the surface as
well
the reason I ask that though is there is
I talk about it in the book in chapter 3
when I'm talking about this kind of idea
of the field of play and the identity
that how it gets created that there is a
we have our core self which is just this
place of like pure possibility and you
know one of the the big ideas behind the
alter ego effect is that one of the
great things that makes human beings
truly unique on this planet it's not
that we can love because other animals
display that not I'm not discounting the
power of it I'm just saying it's not the
thing that makes us really unique what
makes human beings truly unique is our
ability to tap into a creative
imagination to create a heaven from hell
or a hell from heaven or to you know
suspend the disbelief for a moment so
that we can unleash just a different
self and show up like we know that we
can but we sometimes block it because of
again shame trauma impostor syndrome or
any one of a number of things and so in
order for me to kind of explain this out
for people I had to come up with some
sort of model to help kind of just
reflect back how we end up showing up in
performance on whatever field of play
and performances like as a parent it's
as a friend it's in work it's whatever
and and I talk about how just beyond the
the inside core of you know that self
that's inside of all of us it's just
like kind of pure potentiality and it's
not about getting we want it but it's
like that is it's there I've seen it
happen with people just completely
transformative results happen in a flash
because they connect with that idea that
no like there is a creative self inside
of me that I can decide and be with
intention have that show up for me
but rate outside that layer is this
layer that I call core drivers and core
drivers are often things that happen
underneath the surface for people and
shape
their behavior and they don't realize
that it's shaping an example is we can a
core driver is a saying you know I'm an
American or I'm a Canadian that's a core
driver we end up taking on these kind of
these these behaviors these value sets
in these beliefs based on on that
because now it's you know it's something
that's a bigger part of who we are it's
not just me it's actually something
that's larger than I'm connected to it
could be the tribe of people that we
hang out with it could be the religion
that you're a part of it could be the it
could be the group like you've got I've
worked with US Marines and Navy SEALs
and you know there's a different there's
a there's a a code that they operate
after and one of the other ones is
values
that's what values are so important and
we does I just I'll look in up them with
people and then see well is that person
honoring that value or have they
attached a narrative to that value
that's just that's not quite right
that's actually having it causing them
to rev the engine more than it needs to
and you know it's not like I discovered
anything you know radically different
about the values that you have but you
know just your idea that in order for
you in order for success for uniform in
order P to point at success suffering
needs to be there is definitely not true
that's a belief that you own and
intellectually I agree with you and I
understand that yeah but there's a gap
between that understanding and actually
doing anything about it yeah and this is
something I've had self awareness around
for a long time but it's only now that
I've decided like I'm actually going to
attempt yeah to do this differently and
today is a perfect example because I
have a show going up tonight mm-hmm
normally I would have put in a huge
number of hours of like getting all
involved in the minutiae of it and I
have haven't even looked at it yet yeah
after this show I'm gonna have to get
into it and I'm gonna get it up but but
my relationship to it is different and
that is where the discomfort is coming
from but I have to create those new
neural pathways
and I have to get on the other side of
it okay tonight it will post over the
next couple days I'll see how its
received and responded to and of course
that will have no bearing on like the
the amount of pain that I'm going to
experience later today getting it
published right I understand that it's
just walking that walk as opposed to the
theoretical understanding of it yeah I
think an useful idea for people to to
get engaged with too is around the idea
of all all of us are born in with just
classic intrinsic motivators the things
that intrinsically motivated you know
any outside effect needed things like
growth growth is a natural intrinsic
motivator that's why the moment that a
young child who might be involved in
sport doesn't see themselves constantly
progressing and growing they will become
bored with it so growth is an intrinsic
motivator another one is learning which
is different from growing learning is an
intellectual activity and when we're
learning we stay engage with something
as well and you got things like
adventure another one that and
exploration exploring that's why young
infants are constantly reaching out with
their hands and exploring the world
around them they're trying to figure it
out map the world but curiosity is
another one that's lost with many people
and I think it's something that for
people who are and I mean I can be a
control freak too that's why I know this
quite well and but curiosity is another
powerful intrinsic motivator to tap into
where it's like you know you had said
I'm willing to and there's a big
difference between the word interested
and committed it's the thing I'm always
testing I did I had a opportunity to do
something with the United States Navy a
big project opportunity and when I was
talking to the head of that project I
just asked him flat-out are you
interested in this project being
successful or are you committed to it
because it's too vastly different
outcomes for us I mean you have to be
willing to
a lot of the paradigms that you operate
with because it'll just run counter to
exactly how we're going to be
implementing this and he thought about
it for a moment and because most people
that are in corporate or high positions
are very risk-averse
he said we're probably very interested
in this and I said well then I'm not the
right person for you because I get to
choose who I get to work with but for
you it's like you're saying willing but
you know what if you became curious
about committing to this for three
months
this just attitude of I am going to give
up responsibility to someone else or
some software system or whatever it is
it's going to be doing this and see how
it goes see how it would shape my life
and shape my impact if I was free to do
other things
mm-hmm yeah well I'm on board with that
you know i'm i actually am committed to
that and i have thought about that
90-day window and and giving myself that
amount of time before making any
judgment calls about the success or
failure of this new experiment and i'm
confident that it will be successful and
it will free up time for me to focus on
other things that i want to be doing so
yeah you know i don't want to get to in
the weeds on like my specific stuff here
but no prob but i hear what you're
saying and i think there is a huge
difference between interested and
committed you know and i think a lot of
people don't spend enough time parsing
that ya know they say oh yeah i want to
lose weight or i want to do is like well
do you really you know what actions are
you taking that would demonstrate you
know the level of that interest or
commitment
yeah i mean the difference is there's so
many people who you know they think that
the scoreboard is how many books they've
purchased you know which is which is
fine but you know just doing someone
who's interested in a book and committed
to the book is the person who's
interested will flip through the book
and let's say it's a nonfiction book
they'll flip through the book and
they'll look at the exercises and think
okay well I'm gonna come back that no
that's a neat idea yeah I'm gonna I'm
gonna come back to that too and they get
to the book and they go into the book
and they go that's a that's a really
good idea and they share with other
people this you gotta try this this is a
great book you should you should read it
too
that's someone who was interested in the
idea someone who's committed will
instead get to the end of chapter one
and sit with that idea or actually
answer the questions because the intent
is just massively different and that's
kind of one of the the spirit that's the
spirit of that's lying inside the book
too is just this power of intentionality
like that this has nothing to do with
being faker inauthentic at all because
faking inauthentic is someone whose
motivation is to deceive others because
that's what if like if I was here and I
was you know trying to put on a face so
I could deceive you in some way then
that's being inauthentic but you know
nothing wears on people more than when
you get to the end of your day and your
head hits the pillow and you think
yourself why didn't I say that why
didn't I do it differently you know why
didn't I raise my hand and speak up when
that person said something demeaning to
my coworker and whatever you know that
in that moment you didn't live
authentically because you didn't honor
the values of who you are and so just
the idea that we have in the book is
sometimes you know I call them like it's
a phone booth moment that moment when
you know an impact a moment of impact
truly is about to happen and sometimes
we have whatever blocks that we've got
we can tap into the power of the
characteristics and traits of someone or
something else that can draw out our
best self because we can suspend the
disbelief of you know what we can and
cannot do
well let's unpack this whole idea of the
alter ego but before that I just wanted
to comment on something you said just
prior to that which is this sense of
accomplishment that we get or we have by
buying a bunch of books right like the
entire self-help industry let's be
honest is built upon that human impulse
yeah of tricking ourselves into thinking
we've actually done something because we
read a book yeah it gratifies us on some
level and actually lures us into this
sense that that that we've moved our
lives forward because we've
intellectualized some idea but that's
very different from actually
implementing any of the wisdom in any of
these books I mean do we really need
however many thousands of self-help
books that are written every year it's
like it's crazy right most of these it's
just there you know this there
there are core ideas that are great
truths but the trick is in the
utilization the leveraging of that right
and the kind of key idea in your book is
this idea of the alter ego which we
should just define before we dive into
it I mean you've already kind of talked
a little bit about it but essentially
what you're saying is that in order to
overcome certain blocks that stand
between ourselves and the best version
of who we are can be there is wisdom in
this practice of adopting almost a
superhero personality of your own
choosing that allows you to create an
arm's length distance between you and
all your baggage and the person that on
some level you know you're capable of
becoming yeah
is that fair yeah yeah absolutely and I
mean and I go into the book around just
the psychological science behind why
it's effective and the history of people
that have used them oftentimes people
that would they would never have guessed
have used elements of it because I say
it honestly in the book that do you need
to every single kind of step of the
process in it to tap into the power of
it of course not and tons of people
haven't
however as someone who's hired to you
know unleash the performance of people
who are operating at a very high level I
had created a process and system over
time because I always talked about how
you know you know you like utilizing an
alter ego it's kind of like truth it's
like the center of town you can there's
many streets and avenues and ways to get
to it and that's why after chapter 3 I
basically say like listen from here
forward if you're interested in chapter
14 and learning about how to tap into
totems and artifacts to you know find
your altar you go go read that one
because that might just prop up
something where you want to go back and
learn about the superpowers and
characteristics and traits back in
Chapter you know 10 or whatever the case
is so yeah I'm excited to get it out
because it's an idea that's kind of in
laying dormant and yet there's been so
many breadcrumbs throughout history of
people using it yeah that I can't wait
for it to get into people's hands well
it's come up in this podcast on several
occasions I've had James Lawrence the
iron cow
boy on the show a couple times for those
that are newer to the show he's the guy
who did 50 iron man's in 50 states and
50 days which if there was a superhuman
feat of human endurance that would
certainly qualify very much and he's
very in touch with his alter ego like he
fabricated this personality that is the
iron cowboy which is very different from
James Lawrence and when asked
point-blank like how did you get up
every single day during these 50 days
and do it he'd say look I'd get up I'm
weary and tired I don't want to do any
of this and I'd have to you know step
into the identity of the iron cowboy
what would the iron cowboy do and I
would go out there and execute as if the
iron cowboy was this superhero figure
that my kids would look up to and you
know that I aspire to become and
something about that process allowed him
to transcend his own sense of personal
limitation to achieve something
extraordinary
David Goggins the same thing he calls
himself Goggins yeah you know it's a
different version of the same idea and
it's hot it's left me in reading your
book and thinking about this has left me
realizing like we like to mock and make
fun of people that like especially
professional athletes that refer to
themselves in the third person
interviews me now
I have a whole different perspective on
this it's like they're they're saying
like this person is the performative
aspect of Who I am
exactly that is distinct from Who I am
when I hit the pillow at night and have
my fears and insecurities absolutely
it's I mean the context that I try to
create with it is that you're not
building out an alter ego for all of
your life you know we're building out an
alter ego if needed for someone in a
field of play I call it so we live on
many stages everyone understands that
like we've got our home life we've got
you know our family life with our
parents or whatever or we've got our
friends and we have our work and we've
got our our sport or hobby self and of
course there's aspects of our
personalities that are coming out
differently that are being magnified in
each one of those areas you know like my
might for myself when I started
to leverage this in business you know
cuz I I played high school football and
that's where I started to get into using
the alter ego and again I used it like
some people do as a survival mechanism
against the trauma and the stuff that I
was dealing with sure and to play with
Anu and to be playful with myself
because you know the rest of the time I
was exhale II stressed and anxious and
it was my one opportunity to kind of
just be more free you know and and yet
that was my actual true self that was
coming out I was just leveraging
Geronimo which was my alter egos name
for a football but I was leveraging
Walter Payton as well and Ronnie Lott to
a Hall of Fame football players and I
was stepping into their characteristics
and traits when I was on the football
field and when I got into business and
you know I said I started at a very
young age but I looked like I was 12 and
who's gonna listen to me I mean I'm 21
and I look like I'm 12 and I mean oh I'm
about to go out there and talk about
mental toughness and you know peak
performance of people but throughout was
I wasn't going out trying to work with
pro athletes right off the bat I was
working with the people I was really
qualified to work with at the time which
is just youngsters you know 12 year olds
13 year olds and just sharing with them
the ideas that I had naturally done that
had helped me perform at a high level
and get in college football scholarship
and you know be a nationally ranked
badminton player in Canada because
badminton and football they definitely
go hand in hand right yeah yeah it's you
say it I've always said it badminton
badminton badminton isn't a very is that
a Canadian spin on the word or probably
probably it's badminton badminton yeah
we could do 90 minutes on badminton and
how that all thing happened but we're
gonna see a flop off inertia right yeah
and so in and so when I looked at this
the self that I wanted to be bringing to
the table and business it was someone
who was confident because I wasn't
confident it was someone who was
decisive because I was terribly
indecisive at the time I couldn't pick a
strategy to to do and grow my business
and I was terribly inarticulate about
what it was that I did as well so
putting words together to describe what
I what I was doing wasn't easy for me
and again maybe someone was I mean I'm
Dyslexic as well
and so I'm challenged by that but not
challenged by it it actually is a
superpower that I have frankly because
it allows me to think in pictures in my
head yeah I think in shapes and not in
words anymore but and then I thought to
myself wait a second I used this idea of
a character when I played football
why don't I leverage that for business
and because I wanted to be smarter than
what I was I had a belief from a very
young age that people who wore glasses
were smart because my best friend in my
small little rural school mark had
glasses and grade below me James he had
glasses too so I went out to
LensCrafters at West Edmonton Mall where
I lived at the time largest mall in the
world at the time by the way and bought
non-prescription glasses which that was
when wearing glasses was not cool like
like it is more cool now and even though
Tom Peters kind of gave me that funny
look of look really you don't want you
don't need glasses but you're gonna buy
glasses right yeah just leave me alone I
can carry some kinda glasses on the
cover of the book well in some ways yeah
and and I used it as my you know reverse
Superman you know Superman put on the
glass to become you know mild-mannered
Clark Kent I put on the glass to become
the Superman version of myself in
business where the the glasses meant
something to me and we'll kind of get
into the science of it in a second and
yeah and so when I put them on I was
very intentional about the person that
was showing up and that's so important
and the moment that that Todd version
that was lacking confidence was
indecisive would start to show up I'd
immediately take off the glasses because
at no point in time when I am that
version would he have that thought like
there which my alter ego and business
was Richard it's my first name we talked
about that before right so when I put on
the glasses I was stepping into Richard
and Richard never felt unconfident never
felt indecisive but the woman I did I'd
take them off and after a while people
know that are in you know this in that
operate you know athletics there's
triggers that happen that we create for
ourselves that allow us to step into a
state that's powerful and just the act
of me practicing putting on those
glasses it was almost like a switch
she was getting flicked on the side of
my temple that the moment that those
glasses went on just this cascading
thinking pattern changed in my head you
should great talisman yep you have a
percent how do you reconcile this like
the validity of this practice is
undisputed you see it you know with
varying degrees of success and all kinds
of people you know tons of examples in
the book and even people like bo Jackson
and like you know so this is something
that's happening and something that
works at the same time when I'm thinking
about this I struggle with how to
reconcile this practice with the idea of
inhabiting this integrated authentic
persona like so much about what I do and
what I talk about is this journey
towards being comfortable in your own
skin yeah so that you can navigate
between all different types of
environments and feel good about who you
are and you don't have to modify that
persona based on your environment
because you're grounded in your strong
sense of self sure so you kind of
alluded to this earlier when you were
talking about authenticity but I'm
interested in your thoughts and and how
these two things are different from each
other or share perhaps more similar than
we might they're far more similar than
the same or then different and and it's
that first we need to recognize that
this is we're all a process of becoming
right there is this onion that we're
trying to peel away and this is a tool
that we use to help people find more of
themselves on the field of play of life
again like I said like we constantly are
human not everybody but many people who
strive to achieve or want big things for
themselves well judge themselves for
their current performance beat
themselves up they'll stop themselves
from getting out on the field of play
because of with a worry and the judgment
of others right that's one of the you
know when you'd asked originally at the
very beginning what are some of the
things that stop people judgment and
worry of what other people are thinking
of them is probably the second most
challenging thing that people have and
because just it's hardwired into us to
get worried about whether or not the
tribe is gonna kick us out it's just you
know anthropologically in us and so for
me it's yeah you can try to get to that
place of core authenticity which of
that's what I'm encouraging what people
is to really find that core self where
you're just honoring the fact that there
is this pure place of possibility that
isn't governed by all these layers that
I talked about in Chapter number three
that you can actually circumvent it by
instead of attacking it because that's a
those things that are stopping us is a
force resistance is a force that we have
to deal with and the force that people
are handing the tool that people are
handing people to try to overcome that
force is another force called willpower
willpower will typically come from an
intellectual frontal lobe place and when
you're trying to battle the unconscious
part of you I just say to people good
luck good luck with battling force with
force mmm however there is a natural
genius that's inside of us called the
creative imagination that allows us to
suspend the disbelief of what we can or
cannot do whatever we think and define
ourselves as and tapping into this
creative imagination which moves the
energy into our the more primal part of
our brain and thinking about geez what
would how would rich role handle this
situation right because we have this
grass is greener on the other side
things I look at you and I immediately
strip away all of the other narrative
that you've had to live with and I go
man that guy's strong he's tough he's
charismatic he's good-looking people
want to be around him and all of those
traits I'm like well I'm not those
things maybe I just someone doesn't feel
like they have those things right now
but I've if I can step into those for a
moment in time or for even longer than
that
I can circumvent the thing that's
stopping me and then in that circumvent
in that circumventing process you
actually aren't releasing the authentic
self it's just that the carrier is an
alter-ego or a new character or you're
having to cut through the the lies that
you tell yourself that that create that
false narrative that holds you back
right so when you're saying well what
would rich role do and you you roll off
this litany of characteristics like a
lot of those to me like don't feel true
or you know I mean like I can't I don't
feel like I can own that for myself sure
and some of them are true and some of
them maybe not it doesn't matter but I
get what you're saying about the idea of
like the idealized version of myself
when I'm firing on all cylinders would
make this choice and would do these
things so if I can create some kind of
mental construct that I can inhabit
where those decisions become easier
second nature yeah that will serve the
goals that I seek well I'll use another
example that's in the book so you said
you know cuz on the cover or a pair of
glasses which again friends think you
know that's Todd paying homage to his
alter ego and you know that would be an
easy place to go to or it's like oh it's
the Clark Kent Superman thing okay
that's smart too but really those are a
replica of someone who led a movement in
America probably one of the most
important people of the 20th century and
you know American history that used this
exact same concept to help him go out
and do the very hard things that he was
motivated to go and do and that was
Martin Luther King and here we are on
Martin Luther King Day recording this
mm-hmm
that's yeah and so I did a talk back in
2004 at a leadership event and I
mentioned just different mental game
strategies that we all use to help us
perform to the level that we want to get
to and afterwards this lady came up to
me and she said I loved your talk and
specifically I really liked what you
shared around the fact that you wear
non-prescription glasses too and it's
funny because Martin didn't wear them
either and it was credits got King it
was his wife and and she and that's
where I learned
story and she said he felt like he was
doing something so important that he
wore those glasses as a way to make sure
that he was stepping into the version of
himself that would help lead such an
important movement and not get in the
way with his own insecurities of that
thing happening and so those glasses in
some ways were a shield to his really
kind of sensitive coarse self so that
when he was stepping into that person
that person was the one who was taking
the slings and the arrows from other
people and the criticisms so that he
could protect that kind of more pure
part of who he was and now there is
actually and I never told that story
because it was always it was always a
personal story between Creta and I and
um and so I was like uh people can not
may not believe me that she did that and
she passed away like two years later but
now there is a monument to Martin Luther
King in Atlanta Hartsfield Airport where
it actually shares that story of his
glasses in a little case along with a
couple of others items where it says
that you know these are non prescription
glasses and Martin wore these as a way
to step into his quote unquote
distinguish to herself I feel like
there's something important about
protecting protecting the idea like not
overtly publicly sharing it yeah like if
it's one thing for the iron cowboy to
say okay this is mild it's fine
but for Martin Luther King to kind of
keep that to himself right it's it's a
private yet relationship I'm glad you
said think creates energy around it it
also reminds me of this is something
that screenwriters and actors do like a
screenwriter writing a character will
have a secret about that character that
helps inform how they write dialogue
that only the screenwriter knows yeah
and once you know that secret you're
like oh it's so obvious yeah you would
never know it or the actor inhabiting
that character will say well this could
be anything you'd be like you know my
characters terrified of water or some
littles or I'm just channeling
you know Robert Redford and Butch
Cassidy and the Sundance Kid or
something like that like they're hanging
their hat on some alter-ego that informs
the choices they're gonna make on screen
but it's they're a little secret
yeah right and what do you know that
secret you're like oh now I can see it
in everything that they're doing but if
you don't know it you would never know
but you're like wow that's so amazing
what they're able to do yeah well I mean
again that's I mean that's I think what
I think just makes human beings just
fascinating is like when you become more
friendly with someone you're like oh
that makes such the book I mean now they
make more and more sense to me and it's
like the very first time I shared with
my wife you know what happened to me
she's like oh my god she actually smiled
and got happy not because she was happy
that that happened to me because she
just was like oh you makes so much sense
to me now
hmm as to why you do things the way that
you do but 100 percent that was your
wife not aware of the abuse situation
and so recently just I didn't tell any
human being until September of last year
so or September of 2017 so a year and a
half ago roughly from right now yeah I
did not share it and there's so many
times where I got really close but you
know didn't um but yeah so that idea of
keeping it private
is something I encourage people to do
and especially like with athletes where
it opens up the doorway for trash talk
you know and that's you know that's
that's why mocked or to be mocked or
something sure and and yet there are
some people who have just such a
fortitude with that they're like I don't
care it's like Kobe Bryant the Black
Mamba Black Mamba you know I tell the
story in the book about when he got
where he got the inspiration for his
alter ego the black mamba which is when
he was watching the movie Kill Bill and
that snake came on and he was just like
wow that's exactly who I want to be that
quick strike and that shaped you know
what he said was the characteristics and
traits that he wanted to bring out on to
the court and you know and then there's
other people where if you're you know
again I'm building a I'm sort of leading
this mission of good and I said in the
book I didn't invent alter egos Cicero
is the first person
mention alter-egos in 44 BC and the root
of that word alter-ego means the other I
or trusted friend which is really the
big which is really kind of one of those
ideas that I want people to take home is
this this idea is that trusted friend
that can help you go out and do the
things that you want to strive to go and
do or help you become the person that
you most want to become
that's that trusted friend it's also
extremely healthy psychologically to
have that kind of healthy version of
yourself inside of you right instead of
that version of yourself that's always
beating you up yeah so help me create an
alter-ego for myself I wouldn't even
know I don't even know how to I've never
put any thought into this yeah yeah so
at work you know we talked about it in
the book you know again like I say in
the book there are many many ways to
start building the alter ego but if I
was gonna you know unfold the process
its first quickly identifying where are
the places that you're most frustrated
we always cut start first in context
what part of your life would it make the
most sense to go and do because people
automatically go to work
sports like depending on their but I've
had clients their biggest successes came
from the fact that they built an alter
ego that was for home life is about
being right we talked about that with
like the Navy SEALs and people like that
who who you know crush it at work but
then are challenged when they come home
and have to be a dad and have to you
haven't have it a different type of a
SIL set and personality yeah so for you
you know it's choose which one that
what's that what's that place they'll
all give you one yeah so here so I don't
feel like I need an alter ego for most
of what I do I don't need it to be a dad
I don't need it to do what we're doing
right now I don't feel like I need to do
it as an athlete I feel like I still
have plenty of room to grow and expand
onstage like when I do public speaking
yeah I have like I feel like I'm batting
you know I don't know 300 or something
like sometimes I go out and I kill it
other times I'm all up in my head
that's a terrible analogy you can see
I'm batting 300 well that's actually a
really great that's actually it shows me
how little I know about baseball I was
trying to think of like what's a low
batting average I want to protect all
the baseball players I'm gonna get
crushed for saying all right whatever
like a low batting average is yeah
because well I would I'll temper that by
saying more often than not I'm pretty
good but I know I could be I know I have
the capacity to own the stage yeah and
and deliver in a much more profound
impactful way than I generally do yeah
most of the time I do find occasionally
I'm not good at all because I'm nervous
and up in my head or you're tired or
what-have-you
yeah so that is one scenario in which I
feel like if I could narrow down like if
I could zero in on some kind of alter
ego yeah that would allow me to get out
of myself yes all my insecurities that
come with stepping up on a stage and
seeing a bunch of people in front of me
that that would serve me well I mean you
just encapsulated perfectly as to why we
go and we we do it you know to step out
of those insecurities is a fantastic
motivation to do it so you know our who
who have you see well let's go back
again to that starting place of what are
the traits that you're currently
exhibiting that you don't like right now
you kind of already I you said a few of
them like one you're in your own head
maybe and I'm just gonna spit ball but
you're concerned about other people are
like how they're receiving you at this
time you're probably also talking to
audiences who aren't ultra types right
you know it's all different kinds of
people but yeah I mean there's a whole
litany of reasons why you know I I feel
like a hamstring myself and I certainly
have people that I look to who I think
are masters of the art form that I try
to emulate and what are those what are
those things that you are looking at
just total comfort completely don't care
whether the audience is responding or
not yeah because they're in their thing
yeah yeah
unbelievably relaxed very clear on the
message that they're trying to convey
spontaneous fun reactive you know sort
of they're not so wed to whatever it is
that they're doing that they can enjoy
the presence of the audience and bring
them into it like there's a whole
variety of things do you feel like you
take yourself really seriously too much
yeah yeah in that and especially in that
context yeah probably yeah
definitely so well then it's not
shocking as to why you're gonna go the
opposite and go well I want to be more
fun
reactive playful on stage more kind of
in your own body than as well so beyond
the fact that you love those
characteristics when you see them in
others is there anyone or anything that
you think as a person as an animal
whatever
also contains those qualities already
and the reason I asked that question is
is because human beings are so story
driven and narrative driven we watch
movies and we get engaged with that
character that's on the screen and they
oftentimes become great sources of the
characteristics and traits that we want
to embody and because we're so story
driven that's when we're connected to
someone or something emotionally the
chances of us embodying and then
carrying out those characteristics on
stage for ourselves is just that much
higher why because I don't want you to
be consciously trying to think about
being that person I want you to feel
that person mm-hmm and so you know and
again how do you train that it's it's
like practice with anything truly like I
said with with stepping into a quote
unquote Richard or Geronimo you know
I'll tell you the process that I did
when I was an athlete you know playing
football is I went into my mental movie
theater and in through two separate
doors would walk Walter Payton and
Ronnie Lott Geronimo leading a tribe of
five Native America
warriors and they would walk up to me
and Walter Payton would collect trading
cards from Ronnie Lott as well and hand
them to Geronimo and then John would
hand them to me and as he handed them to
me Walter Payton would say to me take
these cards and you embody all of us
with the way that you show up on that
field but don't you for a second
dishonor who we are and how we showed up
by not showing up like we would and
that's what I did I take I had 5 trading
cards this is very specific yes like a
lucid dream yeah that's a lot to keep in
mind not even know it was it's so fast
man and so I had these five trading
cards and I had I put Walter Payton's in
my helmet huh because I wanted to think
like him on the field because he was
just a phenomenal he could read things
that other people couldn't and then I
wanted to hit like Ronnie Lott out on
the football field if you don't know
Ronnie was an absolutely explosive you
know damaging defensive player and I put
I tucked those underneath my shoulder
pads and then I take Walter Payton to
the final two cards at Walter Payton I'd
stuffed them inside of my thigh pads
because I wanted to run like him again I
was a six foot tall
scrawny 159 pounds soaking wet kid but I
would play way beyond my size on a
football field now I'm not gonna make
myself out to feel like I'm just like
this NCAA champion because you know I
definitely untapped as much as myself as
I could but I played way bigger on that
field and it was just that ritual you
talk about those rituals before about
you know you getting into that rhythm um
you're when you're getting ready for a
race right that was my ritual mentally
to be very intentional about who was
gonna show up not the 159 pounds versus
that that person was left on the
sidelines I didn't even put a category
of what my size was and I loved it
because people saw me coming and they're
like oh I'm gonna barrel over this guy
and I would just destroy them I broke
shoulder pads consistently actually
straps on my shoulder pads in one game I
broke I actually cracked my helmet twice
by hitting guys hard
right because you're you're basically
inhabiting this Ronnie lot Walter Payton
hybrid
yeah Geronimo character yeah who doesn't
look anything like you know and it's
capable of things that you're not
capable suspended disbelief about you
know what are you're gonna play above
your level but you're also going to end
up getting injured well how does this
differ in the in a professional context
versus sports like what are the
differences between the work that you do
with high performance athletes and
business executives
obviously there's a lot of similarities
there people are trying to perform to
their peak but there's got to be
differences yes so for the most part
with athletes you're in you're you're
with a lot of them you're embodying the
characteristics for the majority of a
performance but I talked about in the in
the book this idea of that moments of
impact that maybe you don't need an
alter ego for every single moment that
you're a salesperson or you know someone
who is you know performing in business
like you are but there's these
opportunities that are you know it's
like a KPI a key performance indicator
the thing that's gonna really help you
be successful and so if you're a great
presenter as a salesperson but then when
it comes to closing the deal you shirk
away from actually closing it because
you are concerned about rejection and
you know the longer the longer that I
don't hear and know at least I've still
got them in as a you know prospect kind
of thing that's not really serving you
at all and so I don't I don't want to
dive into the the deep history of why
that's stopping you
that's not my that's not my role instead
I want to give you some tools and
strategies to help you perform right now
and that's why the alter ego became my
number one tool yet I remember I was
being called on a Wednesday to come and
show up to help someone on a Friday when
they're performing at the u.s. opened
the day later I didn't have time I mean
we leaned on for long term strategies
meditation my go-to easily it's
fantastic at developing focus and
concentration skills because it it's the
it's the equivalent of flexing the bicep
muscle for the frontal lobe right if you
want to get bigger bicep muscles do arm
curls or you know any sort of back
exercise the
gonna strengthen your bicep well what do
you do to strengthen focus a
concentration well the it sits in the
frontal lobe so meditation I haven't
found anything that's better at
developing that but on a Wednesday when
they're performing on a Friday or
Saturday I need something else and all
three goes for a fantastic way to help
make that happen so for people in
professional lives it's well what are
those you know areas that are kind of
you know chafing yurina you talked about
getting on stage
well it's categorically proven by other
people to step into it you know a
different alter ego or you know leverage
that idea at least and do you have to
give it a name like I did or like you
know um the iron cowboy right
yeah they aren't apparent cowboy or or
you know Goggins all he's doing is just
removing his first name no you don't
need to but it's super helpful to do it
actually as well I talked about using
names in the book and how to give you
like so many different ways to create a
name for it um to create a new identity
that you're gonna take out there that's
more playful does it matter if your
motivation is predominantly derived
intrinsically versus extrinsic lee in
other words certain people as you know
like yeah are motivated by the desire to
be the best version of themselves
they're competing against themselves
first is the person who hates to lose or
just has to beat that other person or
has to win like or has to get the
approval of yeah X Y & Z people yeah
absolutely it does that's if the
motivation is coming from the external
part of the field of play that I talked
about in Chapter three all you're gonna
do is still create a trap self because
that's that feeling that we get like
when we feel like we're not showing up
like we know that we can that's that's
that sense that's like not all of me is
getting out there it's trapped inside
and then we get caught up in our own
head of like well what's causing me to
get trapped or how do I get past this
and conversely when you actually feel
like all of you is getting out there and
the all of you that you most want to be
getting out there the internal feeling
and this is actually a term that one of
my clients gave to me
you just said I feel like my heroic self
is getting out there I feel like the
hero that's living within me is truly
now showing up so that in tension that
you're talking about is the intention
coming from external trying to impress
other people well you're gonna get
trapped that is going to wear you out
mm plus you're putting on a facade then
whereas if your intention is about
activating these characteristics that I
am going to borrow from mr. bean being
playful and I talk about mr. beans you
know process of creating his alter ego
which helped him become a better actor
then and you know and just because you
want that goofiness onstage I've got
because I work with people who are going
to a lot of speeches there's you know
one of my guys who's who loves to be
goofy up there he's not using mr. bean
but that could be one of the but what
are those characteristics and traits
that they embody that you're
intentionally bringing so that you can
bring the best self to that moment right
absolutely and in a way that I would
imagine once you're tapped into these
intrinsic drivers then it becomes a
calculus or a conversation about how
they mesh with a core value system so if
those intrinsic motivators are in
alignment with the core values yes of
that person and that's going to create a
potent combination that can be
accelerated by this alter ego which
ultimately is going to be the propulsion
mechanism for success and the magic of
it for me is we had talked about this at
the beginning is you know whether
someone is outcome orientated they're
waiting until they get the medal or
finish the race that's a shitty
existence because you know it's a
fleeting moment whereas this brings you
right back to the thing that makes the
people who are truly powerful performers
you gets locked into the process also so
yeah I think it's important to point out
that any athlete any successful athlete
with any kind of longevity has to be
process oriented in order to avoid
burnout
because they're invariably will be
plateaus you're not always improving and
if you're attached in an unhealthy way
to the idea that every time you have a
match or a game or a competition or what
have you that you have to be better than
you were yeah the week prior or the
month prior or the season prior that's
going to be problematic
yeah because ultimately it's going to
ebb and flow if you're invested in the
process or in marginal improvements in
different areas of what it means to be a
well-rounded athlete that's going to
keep you energized about your career but
that's a very slippery slope because
being an elite athlete means constantly
improving your performance even if it's
those tiny marginal you know Oh point
zero five percent gains well and it also
gets it also gives you a tremendous
sense of control because the thing that
makes you feel out of control is when
you're so focused on outcomes and I'll
use me as a perfect example and this
book so I had you know when when I was
out talking to publishers about this
book there was we had we had meetings
with 19 publishers which if you're not
familiar that were interested and it was
great it was an amazing experience and
we had so many people that were saying
such nice things and this is gonna be
huge and you know filling up my head
with all of this stuff right and so my
expectation now is that this is going to
be a New York Times best seller right
and I'm gonna make this thing a New York
Times best seller well that's an outcome
that I can't control because ultimately
that's a curated list it's actually not
a true representation of books sold and
so I was focused on engineering all of
the different activities that would make
this thing a New York Times bestseller
and I was getting massively stressed out
and then you know one of my really good
friends who is one of the kind of
launching pads for the book
Tucker max I was sitting out at his
place in Austin and he was like dude
you've won like you had 19 people
bidding on this
you got a great advance for this book
it's a great like the finished product
is a great book you know when was the
last time you ever told anyone go go buy
this because it's new
celer and I was like well never and it
used to mean something that it doesn't
really mean anymore
yeah and so it just it just brought me
back I'm like wait a second Todd for
20-plus years you've been doing nothing
but coaching people on the process to
get them locked in the process you've
now shifted your perspective on your own
book to an outcome again
this is the value of having chief
performance officer sitting outside
because inside the bottle I was raised
from the label right and so since that
moment which was November the 12th I've
been just doing the do just staying
focused on the process that I can
control to help get the message out and
the book out and you know leads me to
sit here with you because talking to
Jonathan about hey do you know anyone
that could you know help you know you
know sit down with so yeah just this
idea of that intentionality being
something that you can really control is
extremely powerful to get people to
enjoy as much as many moments of their
day their work life or whatever as
possible it's also okay to want to be on
the New York Times best hey yeah you
know what I mean like that's a very
human thing and that would be like oh my
god what a lifetime achievement it's a
super cool thing yeah so I would say
that it's important to also be gentle on
yourself and not shame yourself if that
is a goal that you want yeah yeah you
know an analogous situation would be an
athlete who's trained their entire
career to go to the Olympics they go to
Olympic Trials they make the Olympic
team that's the equivalent of you
getting a book deal with 19 whatever
yeah team publishers wanting the book
it's going to be predictable and logical
for that athlete to then say boy I'd
like to win the gold medal mm-hmm you
know so is that person attached to
process or outcome well that's an
outcome driven thing yeah if they don't
win the gold medal they're probably
gonna be disappointed yeah so I think
it's there's a place to want that gold
medal or want that New York Times you
know check
but being wary of that attachment to
that outcome not being unhealthy like
having some attachment to that outcome
is what's driving yeah the work ethic
and the investment in the process to get
there right so it's a look it's a it's a
more nuanced thing I think yeah yeah
well I mean we live in this world of
polarity right I mean there's
black/white there's up down there's
inside outside and so you know just this
idea that everything is process oriented
an enemy I am NOT that person at all I
mean I'm around achievers and strivers
you know ambitious people all the time
and so there is this balance and/or this
really I don't think of it as balance
it's this integration of both of them
living together but when you're when
you're doing the activity to help you
win the gold medal if you're focused on
the gold medal in that moment you are
dead in the water well also not
self-identifying with it it can't be a
commentary on who you are as a human
being exactly so the stakes of like
winning that gold medal can't be a
referendum on whether you're a human
being of value or not yeah there's a
there's a you would love this have you
seen the documentary that just came out
on HBO about the surf culture in Hawaii
with Kelly Slater yeah I just watched it
actually yeah I just watched like two
days ago
it's awful it's it's a it's it's it's
kind of what we're talking about here is
the journey that all of them went
through and the destructive nature of
you know pursue pursuit pursuit and yeah
anyway well it's about it's about you
know the love and purity of this
activity that was shared by these young
men but then when money and pressure and
competition and all of that gets merged
into this subculture how that fractures
the community and leads people in
different directions you know so you
have Kelly Slater super competitive you
know was willing to do what some of
these other guys weren't willing to do
in order to win and and and maintain
that status and then other athletes who
were really just in it for
you didn't really want to compete at all
right but they shared this love of this
thing and how you know that generation
had to navigate that and what it did to
those relationships yeah super
interesting I forget the name of the
document I know thanking right I'm
blanking this is something generation or
something like that right yeah yeah yeah
it's fantastic how to recommend yeah I
don't know what are we talking about now
we're talking about process and
intention yeah I think we've you know
covered it too with people yeah so so
yeah it's like it's it's the journey
it's not the destination great it's the
process it's not the outcome yes but you
know it is more complicated than that
yeah you know it's minoo at sad --is i
er for a certain outcome that's gonna
Wed you in the process like you can't
completely you know remove these things
from each other it's their relationship
to each other that creates that alchemy
yeah and I mean what you just said is
exactly right with this you know it's
complicated
and that's what gets we if there's ever
like an objection around the idea of the
alter ego as they're trying to simplify
life down to just like open doors we all
just love ourselves anyway I'm like I
love that idea
but as someone who has had an entire
career helping people achieve things and
through that process enjoy it as well
it's a lot more nuanced and complex than
just sitting down and saying yeah but
you just need to love yourself I'm a
great example of that you know there's
there's a lot more to human beings and
what people have gone through than just
you know waking up and doing some things
like there's layers of narrative that
people have and so you know that's why
it was important for me to put in this
kind of the science and the psychology
behind why this is so effective like the
idea that I wanted to share from the
beginning around enclosed cognition
enclosed cognition is an idea that sits
in our in our psyche that we as human
beings attach meaning we enclose meaning
cognitively to things that we wear and
things around us
and a good example of this was or a
study that was done by the Kellogg
School of Management was they brought a
bunch of students into a classroom and
on the board was have you ever seen one
of those kind of puzzles where it has
five blocks across the top five blocks
going down and in each block is the word
of a color but it's colored in a
different color so it's like the word is
yellow when it's blue mm-hmm and then
it's green when it's red so it says
green but it's red and the trick with it
is if you ever given it is you've got to
go through and say all 25 of the colors
but the word but it's really it's hard
to do it because you're seeing blue but
yellow what color you're seeing yeah not
the Warriors and so they brought in a
bunch of students and they asked them to
their testing their focus and
concentration skills and they said okay
like go through this puzzle and you know
give us the word so they timed them
track to many mistakes that they made
and then they left the room then they
brought in another group of students and
they gave them a white coat and told
them it was a painter's coat okay and
they got them to put it on and then they
did the exercise track the results they
leave the room bring in another group
give them the same white coat but this
Sunday tell them it's a lab coat or a
doctor's coat and they do the experiment
okay
so what do you think the results were or
the differences were between the people
who were plain clothes and wearing the
painters coat the people in the painters
coat did better because they were they
were adorned in something that made them
feel like they were an expert okay so
the stats were zero difference between
the tile really yeah and it'd be cut and
it comes down to because the test itself
was testing your focus and concentration
skills and your ability to see detail
now the people with the lab coat or
doctor's coat they made less than half
the mistakes as everyone else and they
finished it in less than half the time
so they showed higher levels of focus
consecration concentration you know
didn't have as many mistakes because
they were included the idea that when
you were wearing a lab coat someone who
has a lab coat on or a doctor's coat
they're smart they
they know details whatever someone's
meaning was it helped them perform
better again
they performed better mm-hmm now they
did the same test this time they told
them that the coat was the same as a
painter's Co for some one group and a
lab coat for another group but this time
they were just standing next to it in
OHS on a mannequin didn't change no
results change unless it was on them
they didn't in clothes themselves with
the cognitive traits of someone who was
more detail-oriented and then they did a
creative test with them so painting
again this is the exact same coat the
coat is no different whether they just
told them as a painter's coat arrived in
his lab coat did a creative test now the
people were told that it was a painter's
coat they performed the test better than
the people who were wearing the lab coat
and plain clothes so that's why for me
when I'm helping people to develop this
ideal of tapping into an alter ego
making sure that the glasses that I'm
putting on means something and I mean I
talked about in the book how there's
been many studies have been done around
people who wear glasses are perceived to
be smarter you know more patient you
know all these types of things and you
know for my client who was an equestrian
rider her alter ego she grew up in the
time of Wonder Woman not the current
Wonder Woman but the 1970s version of
Wonder Woman and just that was Amelia
when I said well who would be your alter
sheep Amelie just went right away loved
her I'm like why what traits do you
think she's like she's just calm she
stands her ground
she's just just filled with like pure
confidence and a relaxed confidence and
for someone who was sitting on a horse
that didn't have her not really that
relaxed confidence that was great on my
kid great what are we gonna use now to
activate her okay what's that totem or
artifact I talk about in the book you
said a talisman and so she went out and
bought a or got a custom-made bracelet
actually that looked a lot more similar
to hers
and use that now for me I know human
beings when we developed triggers for
ourself sound is actually one of the
most important triggers that we can use
it's a very underutilized one the sound
of something so for me I was like no
when you get your when you get that
bracelet made make sure it has a nice
snap sound to it because that's the
moment when your account like clasps on
the classic itself
yeah like the Wonder Woman yeah yeah and
that when that thing comes together I
want that thing to snap in place sound
is just she hold them up to like it you
know
yeah deflect bullets of course like that
yeah all right yeah and so you know just
that I would offer the invisible plane
but that's a tough one how do you this
is sort of similar to the other question
I asked but like how does this how does
the square with the problematic nature
of fake it till you make it right
because I'm some other you're saying
well look you know she doesn't have the
confidence when she gets on the horse so
she's got to like conjure up this image
of Wonder Woman and try to inhabit this
artificial persona yeah in order to be
the person that she wants to be yeah is
that not faking it til you make it like
what part of this is really authentic
and what part of this is kind of
trickery I suppose sure so just the idea
of fake it till you make it for one
thing as a term fails the first sniff
test which is why would you put the word
fake it in there right off the back
because it's gonna deliver resistance
with people because no one ultimately
wants to be fake but again getting back
to the true intention behind this is for
people to realize that okay so her
current narrative is that she doesn't
have confidence on the horse but what I
know as someone who's worked with so
many people she does have the confidence
it's sitting inside of her already she's
just this is a way of giving her
permission
exactly it's suspending the disbelief
that you don't have this right now and
are you and allowing to step into this
idealized version which we as human
beings do
it's that grass is green another side
you know we think that that person is
flawless so I'm gonna like well great
that's it I'm not gonna I'm not here to
argue with human psychology right I'm
here to tap into its power to allow
people to get out onto their field of
play as they most want to so they can
lead the lives that are true reflection
of who they really are instead of being
impeded by traumas impostor syndrome or
any one of the little hidden the hidden
kind of things that the enemy likes to
use to pull us into the ordinary world
outside of crafting cultivating these
alter egos your clients and the practice
of meditation which you already talked
about a little bit what are some of the
daily habits or rituals that you try to
get your clients to adopt okay one of
them is this idea of when you have a
performance that's upcoming there is
this a lot of people talk you probably
heard this as well a lot of people talk
about the importance of visualization or
imagery skills right and for those of
you out there who have heard this before
and are frustrated because you don't
know how to do it very well you're in
good company because it's it's a skill
you have to learn how to do
everyone just that's been a lot of my
problem with people in the personal
development or self-help or even the
mental game space is they they say it's
so flippantly like you just got to
visualize as if it's something that is
very easy to do it's actually not very
easy to do just because we have the
capacity and we do it all of the time
anyway doesn't mean that we can do it
with the intention to bring about the
outcome or the process that we want and
so one day when I was sitting down just
journaling for myself it just occurred
to me that in that moment I had sort of
slowed down space and time in my own
head because writing is the thinking
part of is the doing part of thinking
when you're writing it's the doing part
of thinking I'm actively thinking but
I'm on paper now because I can't write
as fast as I think it sort of slows down
my mind and for anyone who wants to try
to train people
to get into the flow state or the zone
state this is going to be one of my
tools I'm gonna use then so it just
pinged me in that moment and so I
started scripting out what I wanted my
next speech to look like and I would
script it out in a process orientated
way so for people who are you know one
of the you ask the question around
what's some of the daily rituals not
that it needs to be a daily ritual but a
ritual to help people perform if I had a
presentation coming up I'm gonna script
out on paper how it's going to go so
it's you know when I step on the stage I
feel this extraordinary sense of calm
confidence that I'm talking to the exact
crowd that wants to hear me today and
the closer and closer I get to the stage
and shake the hand of the person who's
handing me the mic I just feel this
deepening relaxation as I'm walking
towards him and when I grab the mic to
turn to the crowd I see a sea of smiling
faces that are eager to accept the ideas
that I'm there to share with them and as
just as I talk about how important it is
to find that authentic version of who
you are it becomes like this playful
experience of just read and react with
the crowd and at the end of the
presentation or at the end at the end of
the speech when I end it I know deep
down that the person that needed to hear
that today heard it and it landed hard
for them so you know I could go on with
it right but with it what I'm not doing
is necessarily thinking about the
outcome of the moment I'm not saying and
wanting end the speech the crowd rises
to their feet and throws a thunderous
applause at me because that's not
something that I can control the moment
I start scripting up my outcome the
moment I'm gonna get create some anxiety
for me yeah visualizing the emotional
experience that you want to yeah you
want to have yeah and and inhabiting
what that feels like specifically
exactly so you guys you know what some
of the rituals that is one of my core
tools to work with athletes on and you
know I've got so many that after you
know because some of them I work with
them in a short term
and I'm coming in to just be a kind of a
quick hit artist to help them with
something some of them it's a long-term
thing but probably beyond the alter ego
that idea of scripting out performance
scripting out a day and really engaged
with you know who and what is
intentionally showing up there has been
one of their absolute favorites yeah the
idea of slowing it down I think is
really important like I think
visualization is super important it's
something I've been doing since I was I
don't know 12 years old yeah I learned
it in swimming and in my particular
version of this or the way that I
practice it it is about that interior
emotional landscape well yeah what does
it feel like viscerally to be in this
situation so that nothing is
unanticipated it's not outcome driven
although you can visualize success and
experience that but I also think it's
important to do it like so incrementally
slow like yeah you could spend an hour
on the first you know minute of diving
into the pool for this race you are so
connected to every miniscule detail of
that that it's impossible for anything
to come as a surprise and I think then
it's important to visualize how you're
going to respond when something happens
that you don't anticipate because I
think that's really the the defining
factor in the successful versus also-ran
athlete it's how you manage the
unexpected yeah because we can all crush
it when everything goes our way and it's
everything the stars perfectly aligned
for us to perform at our peak but what
do you do when you get thrown a wrench
that you didn't foresee the ability to
adapt is crucial and if you let allow
that to throw you out of the game
mentally or physically and just unravel
then disaster I'm so glad you said that
it's one of us cuz I get asked the
question all the time well what what is
mental toughness like what's your how
would you define zillions yeah and I say
mental toughness is your ability to be
flexible and adaptable
despite what you're given as
circumstances or the what the world is
giving around you right it's that you
were talking about that flex it like
that ability to respond in a moment not
with that emotional self that's maybe
going to cause you to wear yourself out
or just take a stupid penalty if you're
playing a team sport or anything like
that but truly be able to because the
moment you think that your mental
toughness is about that square jaw
rigidity that's not what it is it's not
that it's the people who are the most
flexible and adaptable that can respond
you know you know rejigged their
strategy to to win are the ones who come
out at the end the most successful right
what's your favorite alter ego story
there are a lot of them there are some
really unique ones the one that I share
at the very beginning of the book which
made a big difference for me because
it's about Jackson one yeah you want you
just tell that story sure so I was
speaking at an event in Atlanta Georgia
and I was waiting backstage in the green
room to come out for my talk which is
gonna happen in about 15 minutes and I
was by myself in the room and all of a
sudden through the doorway came this
like really physical specimen is it of a
human being and in my head I was like oh
how I used to play that guy in Nintendo
all the time and and it was bo Jackson
and he started walking towards me and
he's like hi I'm Bo Jackson and I said
yeah I know who you are I'd be a pretty
terrible person in sport if I didn't
know who the only to sport all-star was
in pro in pro sports and I said you know
I played you a lot on Tecmo Bowl as a
kid he won me a lot of games any
laughing he's like yeah you're not the
first one to say that and he asked you
like what do you are you here to talk
and I said yeah what are you gonna talk
about the kids and what the coach is and
I said well I'm gonna talking about like
mental toughness strategies and tools
but specifically gonna talk to them
about you know using an alter ego to go
out there and truly untap those traits
and characteristics that are naturally
inside of you so you're not caught up in
your own head and he stopped and I'll
just never forget his face because he
kind of got this really quizzical look
and he just looked at me and he cocked
his head to the side he said
you know Bo Jackson never played it down
to football his entire life and I was
like interesting tell me more I like how
he used the third purse I know yeah
that's what you said before it's it's
it's so classic and that's what I mean
before about the whole idea of
breadcrumbs have been laid throughout to
really point to people that this is a
very healthy thing for you to do so
anyways he he then said you know when I
was a lot of people who know my
backstory know that when I was a
youngster or when I was a young kid I
was very angry kid you know misbehaved
and I would take that anger out onto the
playing field but it would get me into a
lot of trouble take bad penalties be
very uncoachable and so one night I was
watching a movie and I saw this
character come on the screen and
immediately I was like I want to be him
he's cold he's methodical he's
calculating and if I could just step
into that when I go in the football
field I won't take so many penalties I
won't be so angry while I'm out there
because this person wasn't angry and it
was Jason from Friday the 13th which is
which shows the power of the human mind
and how he did if people go what he saw
someone who was angry and filled with
rage or whatever is gonna step into
Jason from Friday the 13th and but his
takeaway were the things the traits that
he most wanted to start embodying that
he thought would help him overcome these
deficits that he was dealing with and he
was a just passionate killer yes
yeah and he said listen I know what
you're I know you probably got there and
maybe talk to him about like the
importance of goals but he said I truly
didn't have them I went out there on a
mission and you know I talk in the book
about the importance of a mission and
missions are more powerful than goals I
went on there a mission to just destroy
anything that got in my past uncaring
Lee and and so he said when I came out
of when I came out of the tunnel or when
I get under the football field Jason
lived on the football field and when I
would step on the grass I you know when
my I'd make a heel-to-toe motion and the
moment that that happened
that's when Jason would enter me uh-huh
and I would just embody that cold
calculating nature of who I want to be
and
that's beautiful no you never like told
anyone that though that like this is his
private yeah and so well it was out
there a little bit in the kind of
circles of people who knew him and stuff
but you know he was just like this is
he's like you get paid to do this for a
living with people and I said what's not
the only thing I do I mean this is just
one of my one of my strategies but I
said it's it's such a big core part of
it and he was just fasting with that
idea that this was a real thing like it
was just he thought it like many people
do they're like oh I just kind of fell
into doing yet and I said yeah they just
do it they just they just somehow it
just spontaneously hers whether it's a
safety mechanism a survival mechanism or
some way that they just fall into that
seems to work for them like nobody
taught them down do this or said they
should explore this yeah and you know
just like that exponent was for him
that's why I get excited about talking
about the idea of people because it can
be used for many different things I mean
there's a story that I have I didn't put
it in the book but it's because the
story didn't come out until afterwards
but have you seen mr. Rogers documentary
no I haven't that's at the top of the
list of the darkest okay I know
everybody's and I talking about I don't
want to ruin it for you but probably a
third a third of the movie is talking
about mr. Rogers alter-ego mm-hmm and
yeah his hand puppet the cat oh yeah and
his wife is talking so beautifully about
how the hand puppet was his actual alter
ego but really was the most true
representation of who he was at his core
the alter ego allowed his core self to
truly show up for people which was this
like truly loving and kind and that self
that was showing up for kids and it was
just being transmuted through this this
hand puppet but it's a beautiful story
yeah I have to watch that that goes to
the center of really your core thesis
which is the inversion of the idea of
alter ego the alter ego is
the authentic so he's given permission
to express itself you know uninhibited
yeah and you kind of open the book with
this question of like in the context of
Superman who's who's the alter ego and
everybody says well Clark Kent you know
isn't for Superman's the alter ego but
no Superman is the real guy Clark Kent
is the alter ego yeah right yeah
similarly the hand puppet is the true
authentic yeah Fred Rogers yeah
absolutely yeah
so I like that idea yeah and so and so I
say that because when I go home at night
do I need to bring I know well I don't
bring I don't wear my glasses around my
kids not because you know where a hand
puppet yeah exactly I walk in the door I
go huh I I said Mel Gibson movie throw
you out a hand puppet was it Lethal
Weapon no no no no is more recent I
think it's directed by Jodie Foster I
can't remember Blake you know you're
talking about the beaver yeah the beaver
oh no something about that too oh geez
anyway yes look into it um yeah so but
when I go home you know I stopped at the
I stopped at the self at doorway and I
actually kind of talked with this of
people is there's certain trigger points
that we can use to actually you know
just stop for a moment and just think
about okay intentionally who do I want
to bring who do I want to bring at my
core to this moment and and doorways are
a fantastic triggering point for people
to to you so anyways I get home and I
live in New York City and as a before I
walk through threshold just stop because
so much of us are so many of us who do
work hard like I I love my business I
love the the work I get to do and we can
expend a lot of energy throughout the
day and then we go home and our families
get left with whatever is left and and
that's not what I want for my kids I'm
super fortunate right now that I've got
they're all really young and they all
like me right now a few more years and
it could be a different story but that
that kind of idea of who I want to show
up is someone who shows up a lot more
like mr. Rogers they don't want you know
smart articulate confident and decisive
Todd showing up they want playful fun
get on the floor and
roll around with them and can piggyback
right they want that version of who me
and he lives inside of me absolutely
that's inside of me but I'm being very
mindful and resetting myself saying you
know if I can be just a little bit more
like Fred Rogers because I am a
hard-charging person and I could maybe
have the tendency to you know amp up
myself more than my kids ever need
mm-hmm but what would mr. Rogers do well
he's always gonna get down on one knee
and go eye to eye with his kids so I'm
always gonna try to embody that and
develop those characteristics and be
intentional so when I go through the
door my glasses aren't on I have a
little bracelet that my daughter Molly
made for me that's sitting on a little
hook right there and it's the first
thing I do is I grab that I put it on
and I snap it because that snapping
sound I hear it that's the talisman to
trigger you into Fred Rogers mode yeah
into yeah dad mode yeah it's dad - it is
dad mode and again does that mean it
happens a hundred percent of the time
I'm not talking about perfection here
but if we can be ten percent better
because of it ten percents huge huge
I mean you deal with elite Olympic
professional athletes if you get a 1%
incremental game that's massive massive
yeah so yeah what so I always when I
first became a dad that was the first
person that I went to about who I wanted
and then when I saw the movie I was like
thank you so much for honoring this idea
as well right well all right well now I
got to go see that movie I would imagine
that you probably spend a lot of time
unraveling some bad coaching right
there's a lot of good perhaps well
intentioned now you've just now you've
just triggered me go just out there what
are the mistakes that these well and
let's presume they're well-intentioned
you know well-intentioned coaches are
making because there's you know listen
there's athletes listen to this there's
coaches that listen to this yeah like
what do you see out there that could be
that you're like come on guys
well yeah if you would just do it this
way instead of this way
yeah the results that you're seeking
would be much more accessible yeah well
I think one to go to right away is
the idea that to a hammer everything
looks like a nail you know well this is
Who I am as a coach and so they only
have one way to coach people and it's
gonna resonate with about 20% of your
you know mathletes like I'm a heart
coach that's just who I am
as opposed to being more nuanced in how
you approach athletes so that's just one
thing like case by case like a a
response would be look I got a 50 60
players on the field here I can't you
know adapt for every single personality
trade sure but when you're doing things
one-on-one with them like you're gonna
have a way that you're gonna be coaching
the group of people right but when
you're having and pulling a kid off to
the side being a little bit more nuanced
in your approach to that kid like there
are some people I'm a challenger type
you can challenge me and I'm gonna rise
the occasion you can call me names and
I'm gonna it doesn't bother me in the
least talking to me softly and like you
know this doesn't doesn't work for me
but for another athlete just like
yelling and screaming at them doesn't
work because they might have someone at
home who yells and screams at them all
the time and it just triggers them so
you have a level of emotional
intelligence though to figure out what
approach is going to work for what
individual yeah yeah and that's not I
don't think that's a big ask of people
at all in just any walk of life is to
have a level of emotional intelligence
right another one is understand like the
level of the people that you're working
with right now
like if you're only focused at winning
when you're working with eight-year-olds
you're you're so out of sequence it's
not even funny like this is a this is a
developmental Matt laughs but this is an
epidemic oh it's it's I mean I grew up
in Canada where you know parents beating
on the glass because their kid isn't
being played or something like that is
an epic epidemic up here and you got
shows down here in the United States
that glorify football coaches working
with you know Pop Warner kids you know
making them run sprints constantly
because they made a mistake and they
lost the game it's just like you know
this kind of pop culture mentality to
create a great reality show is just it's
ridiculous it doesn't serve so that is
important like if they're in
developmental mode you're there to help
foster growth it's like again a trinsic
intrinsic motivation if the if a great
litmus test on whether or not you're a
good coach is how many of the kids on
your team came back to play the sport
next year right if it ain't high well
that's a fantastic mirror on your
ability to get kids excited about that
sport that you had them with you last
year mmm so that's one I will say
coaching for some people good coaches
it's a thankless it's a it can be
thankless there's a great there's a
story that's out right now of a young
lady who was who won the national
championship with the Nebraska
Cornhuskers Cornhuskers went back to her
alma mater in Texas to coach the
volleyball team and at the end of the
season just a few weeks ago
quit hand in her resignation because the
parents were being completely ridiculous
with just all the politics and the
bureaucracy and the threats of what
they'll do if they don't if she doesn't
start playing her kid more or whatever
the case is so again it's like most
things it's very complex to try to
navigate this world right now
but I think if coaches would spend more
time understanding the role that they're
supposed to be playing with this age of
group that they're with right then it
would probably help them a lot more than
just it the idea that winning isn't
everything it's the only thing well a
that's such a bastardized quote pulled
from someone that there's a lot more
context built around it and they love to
just reef rate or people just like to
trot out those things all the time as
this you know fantastic well that's
exactly how successful people become
successful well you know I hung out with
Jerry Rice when he was with a bunch of
other younger wide receivers when Jerry
Rice was retired and he buried them when
he was 45 or 46
and these kids are 21 and 22 and he
stayed on the field for another hour and
15 minutes longer than they did doing
the work and in turn what do you make of
that
oh just process he was he just he knew
that you just couldn't outlast him yeah
his process his focus on the process was
just elegant and that's what made him so
special I mean when when you can
literally use a protractor device to
draw out the routes that he ran in
football he was so exact it was just
inspiring yeah well what's really cool
about what you're doing is that it's
expanding and exploring this final
frontier terrain of the mind and I think
for a long time we sort of danced around
the importance of the meant the quote
unquote like mental game and at the
highest levels of achievement whether
it's in sports or business or
what-have-you
you have very talented people who are
all working to their utmost capacity and
the differentiator is going to be what's
going on in between the ears yeah and
that's mysterious landscape and it's
something that I think we've all
understood we need to better master but
we're only now really learning the
fundamentals about how to do that but it
isn't just something to add to your
toolbox in my opinion it's the whole
thing like the whole game going on in
your head
yeah it's not an afterthought like
you're do your training and then we'll
like talk about like the mental aspect
of it like the mental aspect has to come
first and foremost because if you don't
have that sorted out yeah it's never
gonna work you'll reach a certain level
of proficiency but you're never gonna be
at your absolute potential or peak so I
think what you're doing is super
important it's inspiring whether you're
a high-performing athlete whether you're
an executive or whether you're like a
soccer mom who's just trying to better
understand what makes you tick and how
to build a little bit
our fulfillment and purpose into your
daily life so as we kind of close this
down I think it would be really helpful
to share a message for that kind of
individual I mean listen most people who
are watching this or listening to this
as much as we all want to believe we're
headed to the Olympics yeah we're gonna
you know we're headed towards that IPO
or whatever it is most of us are just
trying to live a little bit with a
little bit more fulfillment contentment
purpose Direction sense of satisfaction
calmness mindfulness these things you
know so to that person out there how do
we begin this process like they can't
hire you or you know maybe a coach isn't
in the cards for them yet what are the
tools that this person can start
practicing well as a tool I mean I'll go
back to mindset as a way to direct the
the intention and the action for people
and the one thing that I wanted to
remind people throughout the book was
even though the way that I had to find
this was through something that was
traumatic to me that's not everybody
everybody doesn't come from that and and
I want to just remind people in the book
is be playful with this like it's the
this idea of our creative imagination
being something that's truly unique to
us is so powerful and we have to honor
that fact and in it if you do you're
gonna find a completely new gear that
you can go to that isn't about revving
the engine faster but just tapping into
that you can be playful with this and
it's normal this is not about you know
you're doing this and it's gonna be like
5% of the people who have used it know
this is in an 8 human skill it's an
innate thing that's built into the
genius of you know how we operate and
and roll with it play with it because
you don't know what's waiting for you on
the other side of you stepping into it
and what I do know from people who do
step into it is that typically what is
on the other side of it is maybe 5% more
of that heroic version of who you are
sitting on the inside and this isn't
about
Pollyanna view on life or anything like
that but I just know I the impact its
made on so many people and then the
dominoes that get created because you
know we we oftentimes bottle ourselves
in and we define who we are and what
we're capable of but if I can just get
someone to do 10% more and they enjoy
10% more it opens up and expands their
comfort zone of what it is that they
think that they can do and from there I
don't know where it leads someone so
right just as an idea and as a tool is
start with if we can all act with a
little bit more playfulness then I think
it makes all of us at least 5 or 10% but
yeah so put that sock puppet on your
hand channel it a little Fred Rogers my
god we need that I mean I definitely
know that I need that and look mad life
is short right it is let's enjoy
ourselves a little bit more salutely
right thank you so much new champ thank
you a powerful powerful message today
perhaps transformative really appreciate
what you're doing and the positivity and
the tools that you're putting out into
the world so everybody please go pick up
this book the alter ego effect it comes
out February 4th 5th 5th right exciting
times man yeah we're recording this a
little bit before that but I'm pretty
sure yeah it's gonna be there's gonna be
a lot of activity around this book right
well you can't you can't miss the hi
better yellow cover on it so yes that is
uh this is the trend right like bright
yellow colors on these books I hope not
I hope my history only highlight oh well
it definitely stands out yeah and it's a
great book great job thanks rich I know
the heart and soul that you pour it into
this so thank you for sharing it with us
here you should have if people want to
learn more about you taught her been
calm doesn't meet dog I'm me the guy who
got taught Herman calm registered it
like he was like the 39 real person who
read yeah it's crazy also like a pretty
hardcore like right-wing talking head
personality with your names yeah know
exactly what's so so don't be confused
that's it I am NOT that guy but what's
awesome is I own about the first two
pages of Google so if you did a search
for Todd Herman
my website Todd Herman Donny will come
up but yeah I'm not the right name
pundit
yeah but Aukerman got me and of course
I'm all over the social media channels
like everyone else but that's my home
base is taught Herman taught me
and what about book events are you gonna
be doing some public stuff where people
can shake your hand get a book signed or
hear you talk I don't have actually
anything planned I mean we're talking
about doing something maybe at the
Barnes & Noble the largest one which is
in Union Square is square and you should
definitely do that that's yeah some to
do an event there yeah so I mean if
people went to the website we will
definitely have it on there so yeah I
mean it's it's fun I'm excited to get it
up in front of people
awesome man and I'm gonna work on my
alter ego yeah I'll help you talk to you
all right
I'm not conceptualizing it right I'm
gonna put some time and do it though all
right cool cool
peace peace Lance
[Music]